still in New York I'm hungry I'm hungry
too wait wait wait for me look at this
shape of that nice carats what is that
big old squash garlic yummy flowers
can't eat that for kitties
Oh pigeons I'm not gonna lie that's kind
of a beautiful pigeon I want an apple
you ready to eat an apple nice so what
are we doing in these apples say we're
in the Big Apple
ahaha vegan food today we should be
trying three vegan meals that free
drastically different price point to
find out which one is the most worth it
editor price if you have much vegan
first I had a vegan burger tasting a
strangely needy but not meat burger from
then I've been searching for good vegan
food I'm excited we just ate the whole
core
I need that right I'm Steven a vegan
meal my name is chef B I'm Aaron [ __ ]
son of chef B and we're here at our
restaurant seasoned vegan seasoned vegan
the name my dad actually came up with
the name and he is the inspiration for a
veganism in our household there was some
really tough critics of Omaha we really
put the pressure on her to please our
palates this trial and error a garbage
can taste a lot of my food wasn't until
she realized that she can keep her sane
family recipes but use plant-based
ingredients my parents both are from
Louisiana so I've incorporated that
Louisiana flair to my food basically the
entire restaurant is my mom's recipes
what was the intention of opening here
in Harlem and sexually the first
full-service vegan restaurant in the
history of Harlem we wanted to make a
difference in the community we weren't
trying to force anyone to be a vegan
we just wanted people to know that
there's another option we're both very
good to eat here and the po-boy what's
going on with that dish well those
shrimp are made it's a yam base to make
a batter made from tapioca starch and a
vegan beer and we fry it we take a
baguette and we spread lemon on sauce on
it leaves a vegan base sour cream and 32
seasonings and combination wanted to
duplicate that taste as much as I could
seems to be a hit because everybody
loves it that's yeah yeah somehow that's
the M is just smoothly they make called
powerful soul Cheers Oh hmm I've had a
lot of green juices that just tastes
like the lawnmower clipping lookin so
fruity so delicious no this is no lawn
mower did that happen at this man yeah
they Cheers
[Music]
yeah that's the texture and the flavor
and like the meatiness I'm sure it is a
very satisfying bite experience it
tastes like one delicious flavor is that
just a great sandwich I try to live my
life like this restaurant on the
exterior you see oh there's that
handsome guy which is a pretty face but
we were saying is you're just an
imitation of a handsome guy
no so just like the e/m trim it looks
like a delicious shrimp and even though
it isn't it's nonetheless exactly hey
guys I want you to try one of our
specialties this is a stuffed avocado Oh
certainly well it's stuffed with a
common meat cashew cheese topped with
pico de gallo and our house dressing
vinaigrette mmm through your head a mama
saw I also have yeah oh my gosh I'm
sorry I just saw your mom sorry
[Music]
cute Jeff be coming with a big so good
so delightful so delicious wait do you
hear that
what big in fact vegan facts in 2017 it
was reported that six percent of
Americans are now claiming to be vegan
much higher than 2014 where it was one
person either the reporting was really
bad or a lot of people have become vegan
that's a 600 percent increase what other
things have increased by 600 percent in
the last three years
Oh my problem intake my cholesterol my
old poops the amount that I think about
my own mortality
oh that's dark what has increased 600
percent in your life let us know in the
comments below
wait that all where in the East Village
we're on our way to our next vegan stuff
it's called avant-garde and avant-garde
in solid vegan punch fight a vegan or
vegetarian restaurant I would name it
vegetab loads that just that blow your
mind
I welcome to avant-garde and my name is
Anthony Mancha you see I'm the executive
chef what is the motivation of this
restaurant being vegan kill less animals
less meat environment make the world
better we're not like a health
restaurant or anything main thing here
is to make the food good all the plates
are a little on the smaller side kind of
like a tasting menu so you get each
course one by one I think it's just much
better you could focus more on the menu
items the more you spread yourself out
you know the less quality everything is
you got the Sicilian wine I however I'm
going for the coconut coconut brings me
back to my days in Malaysia where you
just pop on a coconut and slurp away
like the monkeys do yes there are
monkeys outside my grandpa's house
they're actually pretty annoying they're
like raccoon like squirrels actually
really like records I think they're
really care yeah cheers Cheers
mmm-hmm I'll take wine over coconut it
know that is fresh so the first thing
we'll be having is a sunchoke push it
with a little olive oil toasted on the
press it gets sunchoke puree fried
sunchokes
pickled pears kalamata olive pistachio
and some mint a little saltiness we
really rich earthy here you mean toast
oh nice hmm
the combination of pistachios and the
Sancho reminds me of Christmas weirdly
it makes perfect ends actually it's just
really titillating my appetite can I say
that without making you laugh it's
insanity good next we'll have the
avocado salad
we take sushi rice we pan-fried get
served with an avocado distressed with a
carrot ginger vinaigrette
Michael cilantro pickled ginger and miso
glaze this looks so good this is oh I
knew that you would be excited by this
that's right down there that is very
good you're the dance that babies they
do we need a eat something really good
they just like close your eyes and like
do this remember old pepper
[Music]
that's the pepper
are you so glad are you enjoying that
saving next is the head of the woods
mushrooms sauteed maitake mushrooms
white button mushroom puree pickled
shimeji mushrooms a little bit of
kohlrabi and scallions long I have a
confession to make
I'm actually not the biggest kind of
mushrooms really I don't mind them but I
never choose mushroom it took me a while
to come around on mushrooms
I loved this smell of mushrooms cooking
I was like oh it's mushrooms and then I
ate the mushrooms and I was like oh yeah
I do love mushrooms you like mushrooms
now a little bit more yeah a little bit
one I think the thing that gets me is
just thinking about what hey grow dark
damp places yeah one of the things I
love most about mushrooms is just how
gnarly and weird they look like this
alien creature that is also delicious
which is like win-win if aliens came to
earth and we ate them would they be via
final dishes the celery root the
spiralizer to look like linguine can we
make a mushroom stock out of shitake
mushrooms onions garlic we make a liquid
it's called tzuyu and then we blend the
two together and it's a sauce for the
pasta crispy mushrooms on top a little
bit of lemon and garlic smell it
that's that mushroom smell that
converted me to mushrooms hmm wow that's
my favorite it's insane never thought
it'd be looking at my fork after a vegan
dish like this it's so creamy top graves
in my life
I don't even know if they wanted me to
call this gravy but oh it's gravy it's
all gravy come on pop that in your mouth
we're gonna get all day a little game
for you top three favorite vegetables
starting with your third favorite onions
beets yeah of all the vegetables they
believe is about yeah - let me think
about it
eggplant I don't know what this
vegetable is I could do a Malaysian
restaurant and you can try something I
love that favorite vegetable on three
one two three eggplant cucumber pickles
that's all I got to say Adam my friend
we're gone to a special place next we're
going to ABC V they may not know how to
do the alphabet there but they do know
how to make good vegan food my name is
Neil Arden and I'm the chef de cuisine
of ABC V the whole focus of the
restaurant is the fact that we're two
blocks away from the Union Square Green
Market I think you really have to start
with the best ingredients the finest
sourcing you tell me about what ABC B is
trying to accomplish from overall theme
aesthetically there's kind of a mix of
like clean white fresh beautiful look
we're inside of ABC home and carpet
which is home goods store they design
our interior so it's a collaboration
there with the food we're trying to do
the same thing like clean and fresh and
bright but with a lot of texture and a
lot of secret surprises
you know what I realize today let's not
know much if anything about vegetables
it's like pokemons we just gotta bring
new things you're adding them to your
pokedex so this is my pokedex today the
menu the first thing I'm gonna start you
guys with is our hummus we start with
green chickpeas instead of dried brown
ones and some lemon juice olive oil and
we serve it with sourdough buckwheat
pita and some fresh crudités based on
seasonal produce oh man ooh this is the
crudité got a potato chip I've been a
radish chip oh nice this is like
something from Avatar
looks like a juicy cold chip Oh
Cheers
this is the ripe espero Dreier's yeah oh
I'm keeping this so our beet salad is
all the different colored beets we get
from the market we smash them and then
we have a lot of flavors that are sort
of inspired by tartare fermented chili
mayonnaise Dijon mustard capers and
cornichon chives and shallots this looks
like a delicious slice of raw beef with
your favorite vegetable beets oh shoot
this is gonna be crazy almost it's like
an in-and-out burger if you know burgers
brewing the ground have a dish of
grilled don't go shiitake which is a
really nice grade of shiitake you're
really fat and plump they're growing
into wood so they have a lot deeper
flavor I see you talking a mushroom
before but not as plump as this it is
like a cute little child you just want
to pinch its cheeks oh man I feel like
I'm in this forest made of candy there's
all this delicious stuff that I could
just grab off the earth more worried
that there's an evil witch
about to murder me stuff me in her oven
because this is too good to be true it
warms out a fiddly shape cremini
mushrooms chanterelle mushroom and al
Cipollini onion and a little bit of aged
soy sauce with black truffle cheese we
just went deeper into the woods and it's
nighttime the Sun has set and the world
has come alive hmm yo this cremini
though the crime that something could be
so delicious it's so meaty well that
every texture is here one of the biggest
complaints about mushrooms is that
they're these mushy icky things but here
is a little mushroom chimp our carrots
come atop a seeded nut butter that we
grind in-house of all kinds of different
seeds poppy seeds chia seeds pecans and
Commons and macadamia nuts
suddenly the forest clears for a spring
meadow they grab a carrot oh look at the
earth below it is kind of like pulling a
carrot out of the maja whoa this is
what's so pleasing about this tasting
things in a combination that I've never
had before so used to making the meat
that's out of the dish this is the star
when you're coaching basketball you
throwing the guy in at the end the bench
turns out he's the star Jesus that
cauliflower whole roasted in the
wood-fired oven the roasting really
gives it a variance of texture there's
like a smoky meeting this to it from the
wood-fired oven
if you have a Cecchini sauce made with
fresh turmeric that's really a
centerpiece let me do the honors I've
been waiting for this one can i sauce
you Oh wouldn't Assam oh my god I was a
little scared that the outside would
taste burnt but it was burnt cauliflower
just tastes like a crust it's incredible
how many different textures of
cauliflower yeah whenever I think of
like what I want for dinner I never
think of the vegetable component first
that is gonna change for me I don't know
where I'm gonna go to get this stuff
again you want open a farm together
sure
[Music]
back in Union Square Park the green
market has closed and so has a tale of
two hungry boys and their cameraman now
three full boys whose you're worth it
winter hablen Gardner from me I came and
do it never thinking out order mushroom
dish but I'm gonna start ordering
mushroom dishes hey maybe you'll even
turn into a fun guy yourself I'm going
seasoned vegan seasoned vegan comfort
and vegan come together those magical
feelings just warm my heart I think my
worth it winner is ABC V not only
because it was super delicious but also
because I got to try awesome new
combinations of vegetables that I've
never had before kind of price Keane put
on that hey Adam what's your worth it
winner Adam fix ABC V bye we're gonna go
open our farm now what should our farm
name be pigs only
oh yes